we keep I understand you used Google
searches to help you break into acting
yeah yeah didn't I just got out of high
school trying to figure out what I want
to do and why kind of knew what I wanted
to do I knew I wanted to act in some
capacity so I started really just
googling acting schools acting stuff
anything that encompassed acting trying
to find a some channel in and so I just
googled everything and pages and pages
of things popped up and I just filled
everything out and then eventually you
know people started answering and a lot
of those were scams and things I would
ultimately end up wasting my time on
paying so I ended up going back and
forth LA to Victorville scrambling up to
engine one time it was a school for
modeling and Koerner and Career Center
modeling Korean and so they had us get
up on the runway it taught us to walk
the runway and taught us all the names
of the brands and finding new cheap
products different things that would be
of no use to me really but at the time I
realized every other week they had
agents come in for people that wanted to
aspire to get into acting so I wanted to
get in front of all these agents and
when one of those agents came through I
said I want to go in this is audition
day was like every Thursday or something
like that and he said what do you have
anything prepared I said yes I didn't I
went in anyway and I just did the first
thing that came to my mind which is
basically just to jump up up up woman
Cheers I totally get it in a minute and
do some random stuff and the guy saw
something in me they liked and he signed
me to his a commercial agency from there
I began to do auditions and fail and
learn were meant to be rejected but be
in the room and sort of build my
comfortability over time so it would
prove to be a very important chapter
although at the time I just thought it
was like I was wasting my time but I
proved to be very important once I got
out there and we started auditioning I
felt comfortable because I had been
rejected and I've been through all of it
already
so there's nothing left to fear so yeah
those what came of the internet and I
understand you didn't have a car while
you were in Victorville
no not from what I know I don't think
the bus really runs does it run no I had
a train that goes you got to scramble of
some change and take the cherry okay but
that's quite a fit that sounds like it's
several stops so how are you going on
auditions and or or or even to this
modeling class school and then coming
back and that sounds like a lot half of
it was just trying to hustle up money to
get down and get up on the cherry and
some of it was my parents they would
help me every now and again you take me
whenever you know whenever my bit my
bugging them sort of hit it's very life
hi again for what because when you're
auditioning we begin you don't realize
how much rejections involved in it so
you get rejected twenty thirty times
you're like what am I still doing this
for obviously it's not going to work and
it was so much work for us to get down
there that they were just like this is
becoming more than expense than anything
and so I had to figure out ways to get
him get down there on my own after a
while and I missed a lot of auditions
because I couldn't make it but uh you
know and that sucked that was a hard
time because I hated missing him I
rather get rejected and then to miss it
what's your advice for another actor
that maybe they don't have the formal
training but they know they really want
to do this what would you advise them
what would they be googling yeah I don't
know I don't now there's probably there
was probably nine hundred pages and I
Google probably nine million now so
there's much more to weed from much more
opportunity to get caught up in
different thing I'll just state I would
say stay in school stay diligent go
through high school go through college
and try to look through opportunities
after how they sort of learned all you
can learn and situate yourself and be
comfortable before you get an acting
know that you're doing there's something
else that you could be doing no you have
a back-up plan because it's a very
difficult tough game to get into and and
it's tough to maintain even once you're
in so it's not like once just because
you booked something means you're going
to be working forever
so you have to always always keep that
hustle up and continue to look for new
avenues and know that if this doesn't
worry about something else in the back
if that don't work that something else
have other alternatives as well and
don't focus all your energy on acting
would be Monday did you ever feel
pushback from people from even other
actors that maybe they were classically
trained and they saw you booking more
work and they were like well you know
you didn't you didn't try this technique
and you and so you could feel that maybe
it wasn't even spoken but oh yeah
totally you know as well as [ __ ] Han
was spoken something parts you know but
everybody's got their particular route
but the thing I think is important to be
an actor is always keep an open mind
always be willing to learn and don't
reach a point where you feel like I've
learned enough and now I don't need to
know anything else because you know
you're telling the take you so far but
you need to be constantly trying to
develop skills and learning how to
access these characters and analyze
these stories and tell them in the most
authentic light and while your talent
will take you a long way and will take
you to the heights that you want to go
because there's a cap a moment where
you're like well this is just our talent
so you need to constantly stretch
yourself travel meet new people engage
in new experiences fearlessly
and sort of download that information
into sort of creating what you want to
create every role is different so what
may work for one role may not work for
another and vice versa sometimes your
talent will be great for a certain role
and then for another role you have to
reach outside the sort of boundaries of
your natural talent in order to tap into
it those are things that I find the most
rewarding and the most difficult and
they caused me to have to get studious
and learn all these things you know and
get into these different life styles and
understanding so always keep an open
mind and I think you can explore and do
whatever you need to do and realize
remember this game is not a competition
it seems like a competition but it's not
the only person you're a competition
with this itself and if you think you
can't do a certain thing you can if you
think you can you can't just got pushing
stuff it has ever been rules that you
don't want to take for whatever reason
you don't believe in the project or
there's something about the character
you just
feel good about flying totally yeah
characters are realizations from
people's imaginations so naturally some
we're going to fit with your imagination
and so on and some are based off of real
people in our accurate depictions and
some are so you have to use discernment
and figure out what speaks to you what's
real to you everything is not going to
be I think when you first start acting
you're going to take anything that comes
at you can each other work that's
understandable that's what I did that's
what I think most actors did when they
first started out because you need to
work and it's a job but at the same time
once you start to develop your craft and
you can sort of weed out what speaks to
you and what's important because it's
also important to do things that
correlate with your frequency that go
with how you're attempting to move
because if it doesn't you're portraying
something that isn't genuine and then
your performances get people going to
see it and be like this something isn't
genuine about that so just make sure it
connects to you this is why it's
important I think to expand your
horizons and awareness so way more
things have the ability to sort of click
with you because the the broad the more
broaden your horizon is more chance
about yeah I know what that is rather
than living in a sort of vacuum and then
something coming into awareness you know
so I was too for don't know what that is
and never judge the characters this
wasn't what did call and teach you about
life callin start calling Edward is
playing him in this and this movie
taught me to - he sort of established
the idea to persevere and in the face of
insurmountable odds insurmountable odds
continue to push forward and may it
remain steadfast and when you believe it
and the more you do that the more you
may realize whether it was your
attending to realize or break the chains
of whatever change their own their
physical change psychological change
state of course and you can eventually
break them did you feel pressure playing
someone that was still alive that you
knew the film would mean very much to
them to extent yeah I think that was a
little by just a great team that I was
around calling himself being involved
and it helped a lot it made me see
you that he's with us in this so I'm a
tease you know he believes in the story
he believes in our ability so we're just
going to move forward and spirit that
also being blessed by his family he took
me in his house and they blessed me at
this little sort of moon because he had
like a shrine thing where they blessed
me so I felt I got the spirit into me so
just went from there
you